I've I thought Japan was like really on
top of it with health and safety but it
seems like to me it feels like some
things you have to go through so many
red tapes oh yeah just just to get
anything done but there are some things
in health and safety in Japan that is
just a [ __ ] free throw and you just
kind of mush it up as you go along and I
feel a lot of those types of things
where the Japan is kind of just like oh
s what's that it's usually linked to
stuff that's just like well it's it's
tradition yeah so you know people have
been doing it for hundreds or thousands
of years and uh you know we're still
around as a society so yeah sure it's a
little dangerous but like you know it's
all in it's all for culture it's all
about tradition they don't they I mean
you can sue in Japan but people don't
Sue as much yeah like not in the UK I
mean especially the US people people
love love a good soup I think I think
people get lawyers before they get
health insurance in America
Japan you leave a bad Google review and
that's like worse yeah right but it's
like it's like it's like that's a
business Destroyer yeah like you don't
have to [ __ ] I'm not I feel like is not
that much of a concern for that like
when people get food poisoning here they
often don't like try and get you know uh
some um yeah well try to take some
recuperates yeah uh recoup any cost or
whatever from the restaurant or
something that's true like food health
and safety here is actually very relaxed
yeah and it's very much just built on we
just we trust that everyone is doing
what they say they're doing yeah I think
I think the the Japanese mentality of it
is oh I got food poisoning at this
restaurant that's not on the fault of
the restaurant that's on the fault of me
who couldn't you know properly maybe I
like the thing because because a lot of
like the sounds well I mean my Japanese
side understands that because it's like
it's very much this mentality of I don't
want to inconvenience other people yeah
it's like my problems are my own and I
don't want to make it and I don't want
to drag people who may perhaps be
innocent about it yeah right so it's
like I totally understand why you know
they wouldn't like you know there wasn't
like a Karen that just comes down so
he's like how dare you food poison me
sometimes you get a bad batch as well
like that that could be out of the
restaurant's control exactly yeah a lot
of the time it is due to this not
cooking it up or storing it properly but
you know it does happen and I can
understand that why you'd be like it's
just like I'm sick I'll be done I'll be
fine in the next day nothing you don't
need to make a big fuss about it yeah
exactly but you know there's a lot more
of a you know culture for that but also
you know I mean again the old uh old
traditions uh combined with the fact
that I think people are generally more
sensible yeah yeah yeah yeah
or rule we have in the UK or the US is
because somebody [ __ ] up yeah like
somebody was stupid enough and did said
like what if what if I bungee jump
without a car safety what if I run down
a hill with a ball of cheese yeah
exactly yeah this is why first of all
hello this is why we can't have nice
things yeah doing bungee jumping into
hours so fine you got to do it yeah I
want to how did you do it yeah
awesome dude I I was like you hear these
horror stories of people doing it in
like countries where you're like they
don't have a great reputation for health
and safety yeah yeah you know they'll be
like yeah I went to this tiny island in
the middle of nowhere and there was a
dude who just had the bungee and that
was it yeah like I was always you're
always like attached by like two wires
not even just a bungee like I said yeah
yeah yeah when you actually do the jump
it's just the bungee right every moment
up until that you're you're connected
with like two three wires it's super
safe and yeah it was awesome dude I I
still won't do it though bro I want too
much of a [ __ ] I want to do a bigger
one
well how big is the one you did uh [ __ ]
I think it was about 100 meters and
that's considered small generally quite
small for a bunch of jumbo right I think
the biggest in Japan is in gifu is like
210 meters right right and dude it's
sick I want to skydive [ __ ] I think
I would like to bungee jump but I think
I would prefer skydiving yeah same same
yeah I just don't like the deer being
strapped to someone
well
well I understand you have to yeah yeah
yeah like that's just how it is like I
obviously because you get a license I
can't [ __ ] you you just start even
getting a license yeah do you see what I
mean like to me it's like I love the
freedom I just want to jump out of Lane
by myself I do I do I do want to do that
yeah I one day when I when I retire
hopefully at age like 50 40 you know I'm
trying to do the speed uh Felix speedrun
of retirement 440.
um I would love to just get like a
skydiving license and just be able to do
it and take it I just wanna I just want
to be like my hero Tom Cruise you can
imagine imagine being like oh you want
to go skydiving bro I got you yeah and
it's like you lit I literally literally
the guy like you jump and it's me yeah
and I'm like dude
how much of a [ __ ] Flex would that be
yeah that would be [ __ ] awesome and
then you could just Skydive whenever you
want yeah I mean but like you have to
invest rightly so hundreds of like I
don't know how many hours of like air
time to be able to get like get a
license
how many jumps do you need to get a
skydiving license or whatever I don't
know how it works can we have Google
there yeah dude the bungee was awesome
though I wanna I wanna be that but
instead of the skydiving I want to be
the oh you want to go on a yacht let's
go I got I got a license I got a boat
let's go I want to be that guy do you
need a license for a yacht I don't know
you need a license
any boat some some countries have limits
for well in Japan you need license for
everything I assume uh Kai has the
answer for us
that's not that crazy
if you were doing a jump every month two
years you've got your license it's not
very much sorry babe I have to go for my
monthly job I'm sure do you have to
bungee jumping I got the taste for it
dude
you got the taste of gravity that one
that one second where you where you're
jumping and you don't feel anything yeah
that that's a rush dude what do you mean
not because you mean when you hit
um before you hit the terminal terminal
velocity
I was gonna I was gonna go that fast
yeah I was gonna say like
you obviously have the bungee jump
attached to you yeah uh but it's like
dudes who throw it right yeah so for the
first second or so it is literally just
you falling yeah before the bungee kicks
in and it starts to you know stretch and
slow down that first second was just you
jumping is nuts and it's it feels insane
yeah because you jump and it's like holy
[ __ ] this is what it would look like if
I jumped off a cliff yeah this is how it
would feel like just that that
nothingness and just the speed is you
just feel like your gut's just like dude
yeah like your whole body just goes up
and you're because I dived yeah yeah so
I did three jumps and I I wanted to do
each one cooler yeah you know yes so
like a I did a dive the first time and
then a running dive the second time then
I didn't flip the third time wow I was
like can I do tricks and they were like
I probably shouldn't but you can and I
was like how do I do it
and then they were like all right so
you've got to hold the bungee to your
side right and then you can do flips oh
okay otherwise the Rope will get tangled
yeah so and then also it turns easier so
then you can you can do it then you let
go and you want to just return back
don't let it slap like slap your face
yeah so that was really fun but dude did
you do like the did you do like the Ezio
[ __ ] like that's right yeah yeah I
did like fish style I did I did the the
[ __ ] swimmer die yeah [ __ ] down oh
my god dude the shots even the GoPro and
the 360 camera's so cool oh yeah it's
awesome yeah I mean like I've always
wanted to go bungee jumping and
skydiving I've always been like uh you
know you you reach up age sometimes
because I love roller coasters you reach
an age where you're like vertical she's
just ain't doing it for me anymore you
know what I mean I never hit that point
I'm still scared you know like skiing
snowboarding the hardest slopes doesn't
do anything for me I need that Rush yeah
see it's weird for me because it's like
I've always had this fear of heights for
the longest time but in certain
situations I'm totally okay with it so I
don't think I'll be able to bungee jump
I think I'd be too much of a [ __ ] but
like you know for journey across Japan
we're parasailing and we were up like
Christian and we were like no he [ __ ]
hated it he was [ __ ] his pants but I
think he's seeing him [ __ ] his pants
made me really enjoy it yeah you know
what I mean we did this one it's like
I'm like 100 150 meters up in the air
yeah if I was by myself I would be
[ __ ] there'd just be a stream of
[ __ ] yeah I was flying down because I'm
with someone who is more scared than me
yeah I was like this is awesome I love
it just bring Chris everywhere I'm just
like yeah I mean he's a little worse I'm
sure he's going to talk about this one
when he comes on yeah like my God trying
to get him to do any of the like wait
did he do it no of course not no of
course not originally okay so there's
three things that you can do at this
place it's like you should go it's
called gravity park inside Thomas it's
[ __ ] awesome you've got to drive
there though
um so there's a bridge and a zip line so
you you zipline across and then you walk
off the bridge yeah yeah a bit boring
for me yeah mine's like baby it's like a
baby zipper yeah it's very small and
then there's the swing and the swing I
also found scarier than the bungee
really it's literally a swing you sit
there and then a dude just drops you oh
I've done the swings bro and then you
drop and you go really [ __ ] fast and
really close to the ground way closer
than the bungee yeah swings and there's
this massive kind of art holy [ __ ] was
that terrifying and originally when we
made this video I booked for Krista Dix
he was like yeah I'll do the swing yeah
I think he just envisioned our swings oh
swings I've been on a swing before
because you to attend them as well yeah
that's all that we'll do it together
yeah and then yeah of course when we got
there Chris saw this ring it was like oh
well um well actually
um I don't think I want to do it and I
was like what do you mean I paid for it
it's like 150 yeah he's like no no no no
no no no no no I don't want to do it
come on and then he was like I try I'll
do the zip line and right when he got to
the zip line I went first and I'm like
where's Chris and I can see him like not
getting in the ready position to go I'm
just like what come on man what he's
already checking out of that as well no
no he was going to there in the video
it's really good you should watch it
yeah um it's it's Chris is having like a
mental about I'm sure he'll come on and
tell us all about it right uh it was it
was interesting though yeah because the
same thing happened on joint across
Japan we were supposed to because we
could only go on pairs on this parasail
right right uh but there's only three of
us it was me you know Chris and naski so
one of us had to go twice right and the
guy was like okay but we also have to
like think about like the weight balance
and stuff like that yeah and so
immediately he like looked at Chris and
was like you're going on twice and he
was just like yes of course
and then he does those are the first
time with me
[ __ ] his pants the entire time comes
back down he's like I'm not doing this a
second time
the second time and I'm just like all
right well I've always had was stuff
that I'm scared of the moment I've done
it once and I found that it's fine yeah
I'm like that's great that was let's do
it again yeah right but some people like
I guess like Chris or other people I've
met it's like they do it and they're
like I never want to do that ever again
yeah what no I I thought it was safe
though like what but that's the thing I
I totally get people who do it the first
time and maybe they just like hated it
so much they never want to do it again
yeah no one likes adrenaline yeah
really get that but there's a difference
between being like I'll do it once and
if I like it I won't do it again and yes
I'll do it twice it's super easy and
like exuding this confidence and it's
like and then immediately being like Oh
actually never mind I don't want to do
it ever again I'm like just make you
don't want to do it it's fine like I
would fully admit right here right now I
don't want to go bungee jumping like I
don't even want to try it because I
think I'll just [ __ ] hate it but I'm
not gonna like it's not like you're
gonna like show false confidence and
being like yeah [ __ ] it's because you
haven't done it once you do it once
you're you're you'll get the taste man I
think when you do things once a lot of
the time you realize oh this is not that
scary right right
I'd never call you like a beta for not
wanting to put yourself right doing that
exactly that [ __ ] is scary yeah I think
the thing is with especially like a lot
of thrill rides thrill Sports just in
general is that I feel like you know as
a kid I think you're more up for
anything right because you don't have
this concept of danger in your mind not
as much anyway but it's not as much so
like I remember you know I try to I
tried out skateboarding and I was like
this seems pretty fun everyone everyone
seems to love skateboarding I had one
bad fall and that's all it took for me
to be like I don't want to do the same
yeah yeah no I hate this yeah and like
similar things I've heard so many
similar stories to people who've done
snowboarding skiing as a kid they will
go like [ __ ] Mac 10 or whatever I
don't [ __ ] know and then they have
like one bad fall and they've just never
recovered from it yeah mentally you know
it's that whole mentality of climbing a
tree and then you just all it takes is
one fall out of the tree and you're like
I'm never climbing that high up here
yeah yeah right and it's the difference
between the kid that learns to never
climb that tree again and the kid to go
ah that hurt let me try that again yeah
I would always do that if I ever [ __ ]
up I was just like all right well I
could have just said I was that kid
where it's like I fell out of the train
I'm like I'm never touching a tree ever
in my life yeah I could have died there
[ __ ] yeah exactly that's why I've never
had a broken bone in my body yeah yeah
exactly same I have so many bad Falls
skiing and snowboarding I've never
broken anything locally
right so it wasn't too bad yeah it
depends for me like I've had some bad
falls on a on a skateboard and a
snowboard and a skateboard like that
[ __ ] because you're on concrete yeah
yeah
you don't just get like you get grazes
as well which is like the it's I [ __ ]
hate unless you don't get Graces on a
snowboarder yeah exactly that's why I
never wanted to do uh [ __ ] skateboarding
it looked so scary yeah oh yeah like
I've seen some of the injuries my
friends got I was like you know what I'm
a thrill seeker but this just doesn't do
it or were they padded up uh they
probably won't padded up yeah well a few
of them are professionals now right
we'll do it to this day yeah but like
but that's the thing it's like I think
there's this like weird thing especially
with like skateboarding when you start
off where it's like oh [ __ ] I I don't
want to be that lame guy with like the
knee pads and the elbow pads
like because like all the cool kids all
the cool skateboarders are just like in
a shirt and shorts but it's like yeah
but that's because they're good enough
to the point now where they're not going
to [ __ ] hurt themselves they know how
to fall without injuring themselves they
know like how to get out of rough
situations and Ruffles right because
they probably started off with the pads
like you still see professionals wearing
all the parts if Tony Hawk can use pads
and helmets then you can use them yeah
exactly okay exactly I've always
wondered you know like parkour people
yeah yeah how do you master the role and
not [ __ ] just destroying your body
you know when they roll off like big
jumps oh yeah and they just like don't
get any damage yeah it's like do you
just practice that indoors a bunch on
carpet full damage
they literally like avoid fall damage
and it's with this like this droll [ __ ]
that I've seen yeah how the [ __ ] do you
do that I'm practicing gymnasium yeah
yeah well I think they it's uh like a
combination of practicing on gymnasium
and just kind of like upping your height
slowly jumps they ha they jump from
there I'm like even bro even this
[ __ ] roll can't pump I assume they
don't jump off a building straight away
and be like okay either you uh break
your legs or you you just don't make a
jump I've heard horror stories people
like attempting to to do like big jumps
and stuff from parkour right away
because they're like well this is how
you learn yeah I've seen it I've seen
videos of like some Parkour guys where
there's like in some countries there's
specific gymnasiums four parts
you want to know the one sport I do not
know how people get into okay huh tag
tag extreme tag
I've seen that show okay but I can see
that though [ __ ] uh is it
longboarding
oh that bro that's terrifying that like
where you have like a long skateboarder
and just going down a hill oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah on a road on a road with
cars on it my friend used to do that I'm
just like the people that do this must
be born without a Fear Factor in their
brain they took the amygdala out of it
yeah
like you must not feel fear to be able
to [ __ ] do this because Even's just
seeing GoPro footage I'm like no no this
gives me anxiety yeah because if you
lose your balance you're falling on to
conquer it's like if a car just comes
exactly if there's so many points of
danger where you know car could come uh
you're going as fast as a car and uh
yeah it's kind of like it's like jumping
out of a moving car basically yeah by
falling off a longer and you all you
have is a [ __ ] skateboard you go like
70 plus miles an hour
you can't no you can't you can break
with your body yeah
but uh yeah like that's that's one thing
where I'm like someone must have been
crazy to invent this sport you know
there are a lot of crazy people out
there yeah yeah like you know [ __ ]
the concept of like someone like Evil
Knievel right it's just like yeah what
if I just like took a bike and just like
did a 50 [ __ ] meter jump off that
shit's crazy the people who do the bike
like motocross bikes yeah like the
extreme motocrossing and stuff like that
it's like another world it's crazy it
doesn't feel real yeah